hello everyone all of you and every
person living today are modern humans or
Homo sapiens but for most of our
evolution we were not alone there were
different types of humans evolving in
different regions and the most famous of
the Neanderthals in Europe the situation
changed around 50,000 years ago when
some modern humans came out of Africa
met other humans interbred a little and
then all the other humans went extinct
so what happened why are we the only
humans left this is one of the biggest
questions in human evolution in order to
answer it we need to first figure out
exactly where and when modern humans met
other humans like the Neanderthals and
this is the focus of my research i am
using radiocarbon dates to map
Neanderthals and modern humans and time
and space the principles of radiocarbon
dating are straightforward living
organisms including their bones are
mostly carbon which comes in three forms
differing by weight the heaviest
radiocarbon or carbon-14 is not stable
and when an organism dies its
radiocarbon transforms into nitrogen at
a known rate by measuring the amount of
remaining radiocarbon we can calculate
back the number of years since an
organism died in this case 30,000 years
BP or before present we've had this
method since the 1960s and there are
thousands of published dates relevant to
the question of Neanderthal modern human
interactions the problem is most of
these dates are wrong they are wrong
because of issues of poor sample
selection or contamination you see human
fossils are incredibly rare and we
simply don't have enough of them to get
a clear picture by dating fossils alone
but we do have a lot of is the trash
these people left behind stone tools
animal bones and other artifacts
now there are some distinctive tools
that were made by modern humans and
there are some distinctive tools that
were made by Neanderthals and with care
we can use these to infer which group
was present then we have to identify
material that can be radiocarbon dated
stuff that was once alive like charcoal
and animal bones and we need to be sure
that these charcoal and animal bones
were left by the same group that made
the tools so for animal bones we look
for signs of butchery to know that they
were brought to the site by humans
rather than carnivores here you see a
microscope image of a bone with a cut
mark of in it and a piece of stone tools
stuck in that cut mark or for charcoal
we take pieces from clear fireplaces
made by humans many of the bad dates are
because this kind of thoughtful sample
selection is not followed researchers
dated bones brought by hyenas or
charcoal from natural fires and these
dates blurred our understanding of human
history by choosing samples with clear
links to particular tools made by
particular humans we can address this
first issue of poor sample selection but
now we have to worry about contamination
any modern carbon that gets into a bone
can alter the date by thousands of years
so we use recently developed chemical
procedures to check for and remove
contaminants by applying these
procedures to well chosen samples we can
produce reliable dates many researchers
are working on this and here are their
results these are the sites with
reliable dates you'll notice most of
them are in Western Europe and maybe
this is because archaeologists like to
work where the wine is best but the
problem is Neanderthals were spread all
the way to Central Asia my research
fills in this map in three important
regions north east europe the balkans
and the Levant for each region i
reviewed hundreds of publish dates to
eliminate the bad dates that might have
issues of poor sample selection or
contamination then I went on excavations
to dig up new material that I
radiocarbon dated you know how when most
graduate students are working on their
dissertation it seems like they
disappear into a hole in the ground
well this was me for many months every
summer so in the end I produce timelines
and maps for each region that show where
when and how Neanderthals and moderns
overlapped and here is my timeline for
the balkans which is the most exciting
time is on the y-axis from 55 to 20,000
years ago each column is an archaeology
site purple is when Neanderthals were
there and red is when modern humans were
there at some sites where preservation
allows there is a layer of volcanic ash
shown here in black this ash is from a
volcanic eruption that occurred 39,000
years ago in southern Italy you'll
notice most Neanderthals and some modern
humans disappear at the same time this
eruption may have reduced populations of
all types of humans and cleared the way
for later groups to move in even so we
still have five thousand years of
overlap between Neanderthals shown in
purple and these modern humans in red
five thousand years is in fact an
incredible span it's the difference
between ancient Mesopotamia and today so
how are these groups interacting for
5000 years I got a sense of the answer
when I plotted the data on a map here
you see purple dots when Neanderthals
are at a site and as time passes red
dots will appear when modern humans get
there starting at 50,000 Neanderthals
are widespread in the region then we see
modern humans replace them along the
northern river valleys and southern
coast and the last Neanderthals are in
the central mountains of present-day
Serbia and Croatia and eventually we
only have modern humans left so although
we know from genetic evidence that
Neanderthals and modern humans can and
did sometimes interbreed in the case of
the Balkans they mostly avoided each
other indistinct geographic zones which
brings us back to our original question
why did we survive and they go extinct
we still don't know the answer but these
results give us one time and place to
look for the answer during this period
of overlap how did we differ from
Neanderthals
did we possess some inherent superiority
or did fortuitous external factors like
a volcanic eruption lead to our success
I think someday we will be able to
answer these questions by taking a
closer look at contexts like the Balkans
we're Neanderthals and modern humans met
and whatever the answer it is part of
the shared history of everyone in this
room and everyone living today thank you